WITH FAKE NEWS DOSSIER
AUTHOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
FIRST TONIGHT OUR VERY
IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♫ ALL RIGHT SO, WE’RE GOING
TO GO SLOW.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING
ON NIGHT AFTER NIGHT FOR
OVER A YEAR NOW IS TURNING
INTO A SCANDAL BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
AND HERE IS WHY THIS IS ALL
SO ALARMING.
ALL THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT SO
FAR IS ONLY A SAMPLE OF
WHAT’S TO COME.
IT’S THE TIP OF THE ICE BEG.
NOW, THESE FACTS, THIS
EVIDENCE WILL ROCK THE
FOUNDATION OF WASHINGTON,
D.C.
IT WILL MAKE YOU QUESTION
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THIS
COULD EVER HAPPEN IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
IT’S THAT SERIOUS WHY WE
HAVE BEEN PUSHING FOR
ANSWERS.
LICIALGHT MAINSTREAM MEDIA
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT TRUTH
AND TRANSPARENCY.
THEY HAVE BEEN MISSING IN
ACTION.
THEY HAVE TURNED THEIR
BACKS.
IGNORING THE BIGGEST STORY
IN THEIR LIFE TIMES.
SOLE FOCUS DELEGITIMIZING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PEDDLING HOUR AFTER HOUR
FAKE CONSPIRACY STORIES FAKE
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION.
NO EVIDENCE TO BASE IT ON
WHATSOEVER.
HERE IS WHAT THEY DON’T WANT
YOU TO KNOW ABOUT THE KEY
OFFICIALS INVOLVED IN THIS
SCANDAL.
LET’S START WITH PLAYER
NUMBER ONE, THAT, OF COURSE,
WOULD BE HILLARY CLINTON.
NOW, REMEMBER DONNA BRAZILE
IN HER BOOK?
SHE TALKED ABOUT HILLARY
RIGGING THE PRIMARY AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS.
IMAGINE IN THAT WAS DONALD
TRUMP.
THEN CLINTON TRIED TO BUILD
ON THAT IDEA.
SHE WAS TEEMING UP WITH THE
DNC.
THEY WORKED THROUGH A LAW
FIRM.
THEY PAID OVER $12 MILLION
FOR THAT HE IS LABORS
DOSSIER FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
LIES, RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
INFLUENCE THE GENERAL
ELECTION THROUGH LIES.
CLINTON ALSO TRIED TO KEEP
THIS A SECRET.
SHE WENT THROUGH A LAW FIRM
PERKINS COUEY WHICH HIRED
GLENN SIMPSON AND FUSION GPS
AND THEY PAID BRITISH EXPERT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
ACCORDING TO GREGG JARRETT
WHO HAS BEEN DOING A DEEP
DIVE INTO ALL OF THIS, TWO
CRIMES MAY HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED IN THIS INSTANCE,
52 U.S. CODE 30121 WHICH
SAYS IT IS ILLEGAL TO MAKE A
PAYMENT, DONATION, OR TRADE
ANYTHING OF VALUE WITH THE
FOREIGN NATIONAL IN
CONNECTION WITH ANY KIND OF
ELECTION IN AMERICA.
NOW, REMEMBER, STEELE IS A
FORMER BRITISH SPY.
HE WAS ONLY HIRED BY FUSION
GPS ONCE HILLARY CLINTON
STARTED PICKING UP THE TAB FOR
THE TRUMP OPPOSITION
RESEARCH.
NOT BEFORE.
GREGG ALSO POINTS OUT 52 USC
30101, IT MAKES IT A CRIME
TO FILE A FALSE OR
MISLEADING CAMPAIGN REPORT.
NEW A WATCHDOG WITH THE
CAMPAIGN LEGAL CENTER THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY FILED A
COMPLAINT WITH THE FEDERAL
ELECTION COMMISSION ACCUSING
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
DNC OF VIOLATING CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS.
AND FOR FAILING TO DISCLOSE
PAYMENTS THEY MADE FOR THIS
DOSSIER.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP IS DISGRACED FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
NOW HE ALONG WITH CORRUPT
FBI AGENT, REMEMBER, PETER
STRZOK AND OTHER TOP
DEPUTIES NOT RANK AND FILE.
THEY PUT THE FIX IN TO SAVE
HILLARY CLINTON FROM
PROSECUTION WHEN WE KNOW SHE
COMMITTED MULTIPLE FELONIES
AS IT RELATES TO THE EMAIL
SERVER SCANDAL.
NOW, COMEY AND THE LACKEYS
THEY IGNORED
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE
ABOUT CLINTON BREAKING THE
LAW, HAVING SECRET, TOP
SECRET SPECIAL ACCESS
PROGRAMMING, CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION STORED IN THAT
MOM AND POP SHOP BATHROOM
CLOSET.
REMEMBER ON THAT SERVER.
THEY ALSO FAILED TO ACT
AFTER CLINTON’S TEAM DELETED
33,000 SUBPOENAED EMAILS,
THEN THEY ACID WASHED USING
BLEACH BIT ON THE HARD
DRIVES AND THEN ANY DEVICES
THEY HAD LEFT OVER THEY
BUSTED THOSE UP WITH A
HAMMER.
BY THE WAY THE MOBILE
DEVICES THEY EVENTUALLY
TURNED OVER TO THE FBI, THEY
WERE USELESS.
THEY HAD NO SIM CARDS IN
THEM.
NOW, DESPITE ALL OF, THIS
COMEY, STRZOK, AND OTHERS,
THEY CRAFTED AN EXONERATION
STATEMENT MONTHS BEFORE EVER
INTERVIEWING HILLARY
CLINTON.
AND 17 OTHER KEY WITNESSES
ON THE CASE.
BY THE WAY, THAT’S NOT HOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT WORKS.
AND IN THAT EXONERATION
STATEMENT, WHEN DESCRIBING
CLINTON’S MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
COMEY CHANGED THE WORDS THE
LEGAL STANDARD GROSS
NEGLIGENCE, WHICH IS THE
LEGAL STANDARD TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS.
AND THEY ALSO ALTERED A
SECTION THAT SAID IT WAS
REASONABLY LIKELY THAT
HOSTILE FOREIGN ACTORS AND
ADVERSARIES OF THE UNITED
STATES HAD HACKED THE
SERVER.
AND THEY COMPLETELY REMOVED
INFORMATION ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON EMAILING PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
WHICH MEANS THAT OBAMA KNEW
HILLARY WAS BREAKING THE LAW
OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
NOW, ALL OF THIS ALLOWED
HILLARY CLINTON TO STAY IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY THEY WANTED.
AND THEN SHE USES THE
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA DOSSIER.
WHY?
TO LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
NOBODY HAD VERIFIED WHAT WAS
IN THAT DOSSIER.
NOT EVEN GLENN SIMPSON OF
FUSION GPS.
AGAIN, GOING BACK TO GREGG
JARRETT, ACCORDING TO HIM,
IF COMEY EXONERATED HILLARY
CLINTON FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES, THAT MEANS HE
OBSTRUCTED JUSTIFIABLE.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN SEEKING
THE TRUTH.
AND THAT’S ONLY THE START OF
COMEY’S INVOLVEMENT IN THIS
SCANDAL.
AND ACCORDING TO THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE IN THEIR
MEMO, COMEY SIGNED OFF
PERSONALLY ON THREE FISA
APPLICATIONS TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND AS FBI LIED TO THE FISA
COURT ABOUT THE DOSSIER
BEING BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC.
OH, EXCUSE ME, THEY DID HAVE
A FOOTNOTE IT MAY HAVE SOME
POLITICAL ORIGINS BUT THEY
KNEW HILLARY AND THE DNC
PAID FOR IT.
AND COMEY’S FBI THEN THEY
ALSO USED THAT YOU YAHOO
NEWS ARTICLE WRITTEN BY
MICHAEL ISIKOFF ABOUT CARTER
PAGE.
THEY WERE CORROBORATING THE
DOSSIER.
WELL, HERE’S THE PROBLEM
THEY KNEW THE SOURCE FOR THE
YAHOO STORY WAS CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
AND THE FBI NEVER
INDEPENDENT LID VERIFIED THE
INFORMATION NOR DID FUSION
G.P.S. BECAUSE STEELE WAS
THEIR ONLY SOURCE.
AND BY THE WAY FROM THERE IT
ONLY GETS WORSE.
ACCORDING TO THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO, THE
BLUCK,LET ME REMEET THE BEST OFT
THE HILLARY CLINTON PHONY
DOSSIER.
COMEY TOLD CONGRESS HE
DIDN’T BOTHER CORROBORATING
THE DOSSIER BECAUSE THE FBI
FELT CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS
CREDIBLE.
REALLY?
YOU DON’T HAVE TO
CORROBORATE THESE THINGS?
AND COMEY ALSO TESTIFIED
UNDER OATH THAT THE SAME
DOSSIER THAT HE USED TO GET
THE FISA WARRANT WAS, QUOTE,
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
AND COMEY ALSO TOLD THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT THE SAME
THING IN JANUARY 2016.
BUT IT WAS ONLY JUST A
COUPLE OF MONTHS EARLIER THE
DOSSIER WAS USED TO GET A
WARRANT.
DID HE TELL THE FISA JUDGE
IT’S UNVERIFIED?
ANY OF THIS INFORMATION?
NO, HE DID NOT.
OKAY.
THAT IS GUILT BIOMISSION U
PURPOSEFULLY OMITTING
INFORMATION THAT LIKE LIE
HAVE HAD A BIG IMPACT ON
THAT JUDGE.
ALL RIGHT.
PLAYER NEW NUMBER THREE
TONIGHT ANDREW MCCABE.
HOUSE MEMO DETAILS HOW
MCCABE TESTIFIED WITHOUT THE
DOSSIER THE FISA WARRANT TO
SURVEIL WOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN APPROVED.
AND MCCABE IS ALSO TIED TO
THE CLINTON EMAIL COVERUP.
REMEMBER THE RECENT REPORTS?
ANDREW MCCABE?
HE WAS FORCED TO RESIGN OVER
REVELATIONS IN A SOON TO BE
RELEASED DOJ INSPECTOR
WE ARE TOLD ALL ABOUT THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" IS REPORTING THAT
MCCABE AND OTHER TOP FBI
OFFICIALS, REMEMBER, THEY
ALSO KNEW ABOUT HUMA
ABEDIN’S EMAILS THAT WERE
FOUND ON ANTHONY WEINER’S
LAPTOP.
THEY KNEW ABOUT THEM IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2016.
IMPORTANT INFORMATION.
BUT THEY WAITED AT LEAST A
MONTH BEFORE THEY TOLD
CONGRESS?
AND WE CAN’T FORGET MCCABE’S
WIFE.
SHE GOT $700,000 ON
ASTRONOMICAL AMOUNT OF MONEY
FOR A FAILED SENATE RUN IN
THE COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA
FROM A GROUP TIED TO CLINTON
THE VIRGINIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
NOW, MCCABE EVENTUALLY HAD
TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
WAS IT BECAUSE HE GOT CAUGHT
OR BECAUSE HE THOUGHT IT WAS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
HAVE YOU TWO KEY ALLIES OF
ANDREW MCCABE.
THEY ARE CORRUPT.
THEY ARE THE TRUMP BASHING
FBI LOVERS PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE.
THEY ARE PLAYERS NUMBER FOUR
AND FIVE.
PAGE ACTUALLY SERVED AS THE
LEGAL COUNSEL TO MCCABE.
AS FOR STRZOK, LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU HE IS AT
THE EPICENTER OF THE
SCANDAL, EVERY SCANDAL,
EVERY ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF.
NOW STRZOK IS A FORMER TOP
FBI COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL.
HE IS THE ONE THAT SIGNED
OUT DOCUMENTS THAT KINGDOM
OFF THINK PHONY RUSSIA
PROBE.
HE ALSO OVERSOUGHT
INTERVIEWS OF LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN.
HE IS THE GUY WHO
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON
AND HER TOP AIDES.
WE HAVE ALREADY TOLD YOU HOW
STRZOK PLAY AUDIT KEY ROLE
IN CHANGING THE CLINTON
EXONERATION STATEMENT.
EXCHANGING GROSS NEGLIGENCE
AND EXTREME CARELESSNESS.
>> THEN THERE IS STRZOK AND
PADGES EXTREME HATRED OF
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY CALLED HIM A I HAD OUT,
MENACE, LOATHE SOME HUMAN
BEING.
THEY SAID IF TRUMP AND
CLINTON UP-TO-THE-MINUTED TO
WIN 100 MILLION TO ZERO, AND
STRZOK AND PAGE ALSO TALKED
WITH WHO WE THINK IS ANDREW
MCCABE ABOUT THAT INSURANCE
POLICY?
GOD FORBID DONALD TRUMP WINS
THE ELECTION U YESTERDAY WE
GOT A NEW BATCH OF TEXT
MESSAGES THAT SHOW THEIR
INHERENT ANTI-TRUMP BIAS.
IN THE LEAD UP, OF COURSE,
TO THE ELECTION.
LISA PAGE WAS FEARFUL, OH MY
GOSH, DONALD TRUMP IS GOING
TO WIN.
ON ELECTION DAY STRZOK
WRITES BACK OH MY GOD.
THIS IS BLANKING TERRIFYING.
AND THE FOLLOWING DAY HE
SAYS OH MY GOD, I’M SO
DEPRESSED.
AND A COUPLE OF DAYS LATER
LISA PAGE WRITES:  WELL, I
BOUGHT ALL THE PRESIDENT’S
MEN, FIGURE I FEED TO BRUSH
UP ON WATERGATE, THE
INSURANCE PEOPLE.
THEN LATER PAGE SENDS A
MESSAGE THAT READS, GOD,
BEING HERE MAKES ME ANGRY.
LOTS OF HIGHFALUTIN NATIONAL
SECURITY TALK.
AND MEANWHILE WE HAVE OUR
TASK AHEAD OF US.
WONDER IF THAT’S TIED TO THE
INSURANCE POLICY?
WHAT DOES PAGE MEAN BY TASK?
WHEN YOU PUT ALL OF THIS
TOGETHER, WITH THE INSURANCE
POLICY TEXT, IT RAISES
SERIOUS, SERIOUS RED FLAGS.
NOW, THESE LOVE BIRDS ALSO
MESSAGED BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MULLEN.
REMEMBER, THEY HAD FIVE
MONTHS OF MISSING TEXTS?
WELL, RIGHT AFTER ROBERT
MUELLER WAS APPOINTED ON
MAY 19TH, TWO DAYS AFTER THE
APPOINTMENT, STRZOK WAS
DEBATING ABOUT JOINING THE
INVESTIGATION.
STRUCK ASKED HIS LOVER PAGE
AN INVESTIGATION LEADING TO
IMPEACHMENT?
EVEN BEFORE MUELLER’S PROBE.
EVEN BEFORE IT GOT STARTED
OF STRZOK AND PAGE WERE TOG
ABOUT IMPEACHING PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
NOW, THIS PART IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
DURING THE SAME BACK AND
FORTH, STRZOK TEXTS WELL YOU
AND I BOTH KNOW THE ODDS ARE
NOTHING.
IF I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKELY,
I WOULD BE THERE NO
QUESTION.
MEANING WITH MUELLER.
I HESITATE IN PART BECAUSE
OF MY GUT SENSE AND CONCERN
THERE’S NO BIG THERE THERE.
PRETTY STUNNING ADMISSION.
NOW, STRZOK HELPED START THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION BUT HE
THOUGHT THERE WAS NO THERE
THERE.
ALSO DIRECTLY WRAPPED UP IN
ALL OF THIS IS THE DEMOTED
DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR AND
HIS WIFE NELLIE.
THEY ARE PLAYERS SIX AND
SEVEN IN THIS GAME IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT A GAME OF
CORRUPTION.
BRUCE OHR REPRIMANDED AT THE
DOJ WHEN IT WAS DISCOVERED
HE WAS MEETING WITH FUSION
GPS BEFORE AND AFTER THE
ELECTION.
OHR’S OFFICE TOWER DAYS DOWN
FROM ROD ROSENSTEIN.
HIS WIFE NELLIE WORKED AT
FUSION GPS.
HER JOB FOCUSING IN ON THE
ANTI-TRUMP DOSSIER.
AINCLUDING TO THE MEMO BRUCE
OHR TOLD INVESTIGATORS HE
HAD A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE DOSSIER AUTHOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
OHR SAID HE WAS DESPERATE
THAT DONALD TRUMP NOT GET
ELECTED AND WAS THAT THE
ABOUT HIM NOT BEING
PRESIDENT.
PRETTY AMAZING.
I COULDN’T WRITE THIS IN A
NOVEL.
NOW WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
LORETTA LYNCH PLAYER NUMBER
8 IN ALL OF THIS.
ACCORDING TO TESTIMONY FROM
FORMER DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
LYNCH INSTRUCTED THE FBI TO
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON AS A MATTER.
DON’T CALL IT AN
INVESTIGATION.
DON’T CALL IT WHAT IT REALLY
IS AND THEN IT GOT WORSE.
IN JUNE OF 2016, WHILE THE
FBI SO-CALLED INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING,
BILL CLINTON IS MEETING WITH
LORETTA LYNCH ON A TARMAC
FOR 40 MINUTES.
LYNCH SAID THE MEETING WAS
ABOUT GRANDCHILDREN AND
GOLF.
THE FORMER A.G. ANNOUNCED
SHE WAS STEPPING AWAY FROM
THE INVESTIGATION AFTER
THIS.
AND SHE JUST ACCEPT THE
FBICONCLUSION.
KEEP IN MIND THIS ALL TOOK
PLACE BEFORE HILLARY CLINTON
WAS INTERVIEWED ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY WEEKEND BY
OUT FBI AND EXONERATED THE
NEXT BUSINESS DAY.
AFTER LYNCH ANNOUNCED THAT
SHE WAS TAKING A BACKSEAT TO
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION,
STRZOK LITERALLY TEXTS PAGE
AND SAYS TIMING LOOKS LIKE
HELL, PAGE REPLIES YEAH,
AWFUL TIMING AND THEN ADDS
OH, IT’S A REAL PROFILE IN
COURAGE TALKING ABOUT LYNCH
SINCE SHE KNOWS NO CHARGES
WILL BE BROUGHT.
NOW, FOUR DAYS LATER, COMEY
HOLDS HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
WHERE HE INFAMOUSLY
ANNOUNCES THE FBI IS NOT
RECOMMENDING CHARGES AGAINST
CLINTON.
AFTER 13 AND A HALF MINUTES
LAYING OUT A DAMNING CASE
AGAINST HILLARY.
ROD ROSENSTEIN IS ALSO A
PLAYER IN ALL OF THIS, THIS
ONGOING FISA SCANDAL.
NUMBER 9 TONIGHT.
FIRST AND FOREMOST
ROSENSTEIN OVERSEAS THE
ENTIRE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
HE WAS THE OFFICIAL
RESPONSIBLE FOR APPOINTING
ROBERT MUELLER AS A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
WE HAVE MORE ON MUELLER IN A
MINUTE.
FIRST, WE KNOW THAT IT WAS
ROSENSTEIN WHO SIGNED OFF ON
ONE OF THE APPLICATIONS TO
EXTEND THE FISA WARRANT
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND THEN YOU HAVE PRESIDENT
OBAMA, OH, YEAH, WHAT ABOUT
HIM?
WE WILL CALL HIM PLAYER
NUMBER 10 TONIGHT.
IF RUSSIA INTERFERING IN OUR
ELECTION WAS SO TROUBLING,
WHY DIDN’T THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SAY SOMETHING
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION?
WE NOW HAVE AN NTSB NEWS
REPORT THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
WASN’T TOO WORRIED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE, QUOTE:  THEY
THOUGHT THAT HILLARY WAS
GOING TO WIN.
WELL, WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU IF HILLARY WINS IT’S
OKAY?
AND THEN THE CHERRY ON TOP
IS ROBERT MUELLER.
WE WILL CALL HIM PLAYER
NUMBER 11 TONIGHT.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HEADING
UP THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION,
WE KNOW THAT MUELLER HIRED
AN EXTREMELY, I MEAN
EXTREMELY PARTISAN TEAM
FILLED WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAD GIVEN OVER 50 GRAND BUT
ONLY TO DEMOCRATS.
NO MONEY TO DONALD TRUMP.
WE KNOW WHO THEY GAVE MONEY
OBAMA, CLINTON, AND THE DNC.
WE ALSO KNOW MUELLER IS BEST
FRIENDS, BFF WITH JAMES
COMEY.
WE KNOW THAT HE INTERVIEWED
WITH TRUMP TO BE THE NEXT
FBI DIRECTOR.
AND THE DAY BEFORE HE WAS
APPOINTED SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
WHEN THAT INTERVIEW TOOK
PLACE.
SO IT’S ALL VERY SUSPICIOUS.
AND THOSE ARE JUST THE MAIN
KEY PLAYERS IN ALL OF THIS.
IT GETS COMPLICATED BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
IS UNDERSTANDING THIS
BECAUSE AS WE MOVE FORWARD,
I WOULD GUARANTEE ALMOST AT
THIS POINT THERE IS GOING TO
BE MASSIVE INVESTIGATIONS
AND I WOULD NOT AT ALL BE